[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants nous venons de faire
un très long voyage
nous sommes allés dans beaucoup de pays
et nous avons vu de très gentils petits
enfants qui mangent bien leur soupe et
qui vont se coucher
sagement chaque soir n'est ce pas
nounours oh oui ce qu'ils étaient
mignons ce petit son front mais je
préfère tout de même nicolas et
pimprenelle j'ai hâte de les revoir
patron vas-y mon gros nounours et en
bracelet bien fort de ma part on peut
battre nicolas dimanche aujourd'hui
c'est ce soir que tu marchand de sable
qui revient aux commandes de cela tu
sais pas lire les pages et compter sur
mes doigts
bonsoir les ont fait nicolas mas parti
doucement les enfants ça c'est pour
nicolas
je n'ai pas pu arriver à temps pour sa
fête mais je lui apporter un peu
on peut te min en hausse c'est vrai et
ça c'est pour pas première du chocolat
merci nous
j'adore le chocolat et moi ou ce qu'elle
est bon ce bateau on en sait nous nous
te fais un gros baiser
j'en ai pas encore de comme ça ah oui
qu'il est beau on dire vrai il m'a
évidemment venu on va le mettre dans
l'eau
y'a pas trop d'eau il ne faut pas faire
une inondation sinon les voisins je vous
donne rendez nous nous il est formidable
il flotte tout seul
voilà patron ravir il faut que je me
sauve les petits sinon le marchand de
sable à broder
allez vite aux totaux un énorme on y va
tout chez lui
où
oui
d'où ses menottes tu dois être fatigué
c'est long voyage ça faty a vu te
coucher un canot tu vas plus de chocolat
ou ce que ce pour rien
tu as fait pour moi
elle reste en on ne mangera de taxes
jute la lumière bonne nuit les petits
bonne nuit mon n'ose pas demi nicolas et
pimprenelle
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit
petit pas pr neil buhne 8 tous les
enfants embrasser bien fort vos papa et
maman est allée vite vous coucher on y
va patron oui mon gros nounours en route
bonne nuit les enfants à demain à deux
bons
[Musique]